hi there steve kaufman here uh
gonna
talk today a little bit more about my
adventures in learning arabic again if
you enjoyed these videos please
subscribe
okay arabic
my first task that i've assigned to
myself is to become more familiar with
the writing system because if i can read
then a lot of stuff becomes available to
me
stories even grammar explanations
dictionary if i can't read then i can't
access these things now with regard to
the reading
i'm taking the approach that i'm
gradually going to discover this
language arabic the reading through a
variety of things that i'm doing
typing on lexi logos reading listening
to the text to speech gradually it
becomes a little clearer it's always
frustrating when you can't remember
the letter or
the form of that letter inside the word
as opposed to
the way it looks at the beginning or as
a standalone and so it's it is
frustrating that we can't remember
things that we thought we had learned
however i am continuing with my sort of
approach to i just want to discover i
just want to learn
through
exposure
and seeing how the different language
different letters perform i want to
gradually get used to it one bit of
advice that carries over from golf my
wife and i were playing golf and
one of the marshals on the course is
also a very good golfer and he came by
and he
saw me hit a ball into the into the pond
there and he said you know what you need
to do is this he gave me one simple tip
and i then proceeded to hit the ball
very well
and then i said geez you know you could
really help me with my golf game and he
says only one tip at a time you can't
absorb more than one and i think this is
very important when it comes to language
learning
i as i gradually try to improve my golf
game through feeling it better and stuff
occasionally i can have one tip if i get
more than one tip
it's confusing and the same with
language learning so
i have downloaded various apps
uh you know to help me to see what works
and what doesn't work so for example i
found this resource here
and it starts explaining things like
aleph is the first letter of the arabic
alphabet
so here's what they tell you
aleph is the first letter
blah blah blah
most commonly used due to the several
sounds it represents
aleph is a moon letter he doesn't
explain what that is but
whatever it's a moon letter
typically pronounced as a but it has
many forms
blah blah blah
uh alec is one of the three letters alif
wow and ya
that might
be either a consonant or a vowel
when aleph is used as a vowel the hamza
on the aleph is removed and only the
aleph remains
consonant aleph always comes with a mark
called hamza consonant aleph represents
all four kinds of sounds
i'll lift with a fapha we put the fatha
on top of the hamza it might have a
sound like
an and or ah in under
alif with a kasra we put the kasra under
the hamza
note that in this case the hamza comes
below the alif blah blah blah alive with
the dhamma we put the dum on top of the
hamza olive with a second he put the
sakoon on top of the hamza aleph like
all the letters cannot come with a
second at the beginning of a word shakun
only comes with medial and final letters
i mean this is such overload if i had
not already had a lot of exposure to
this uh including on my lexi logos
keypad i can pick on a olive with little
squiggly on top or without a squiggly on
top or squiggly on the bottom and just
see how it
performs so medial medial vowel alif
usually takes this form never aleph
never connects the left side it always
comes with a second and the letter
before it always comes with a fatha
depending on the position in a word blah
blah i mean it just goes on and on i
mean there is no way that i could absorb
any of this information
i mean now after having spent
quite a few days
typing on my lexi logos reading seeing
all this stuff it starts to make sense i
couldn't understand would not be under
able to understand it initially and
certainly i still can't remember it just
based on reading it so the first thing
is keep it simple simple one bit of
advice or help or explanation at a time
and mostly just try to get used to it
i'm trying to i want to like arabic i
once did a
blog post on my blog saying language
learning is like following and falling
in love you have to kind of
fall in love with this language see all
the different features
uh start to like it and stuff so that's
kind of the process that i'm going
through
uh
there are some frustrations for example
you know i printed out what i thought
was the most useful list
of uh i can't remember which site i got
this off of
but a list of all the letters
and but it's not complete because there
are
uh
um
it is this is a good list because it
shows you all
four forms of each letter and it has the
uh sound that it represents so as i'm
looking at a word and i can't figure out
uh what letter this is
you know it's got a dot on top or a dot
on bottom or two on the bottom or two on
the top which is it i can solve this
list then i oh yeah it's that one
because i forget but i continue doing
that however
you know there are things like
you know there's this very useful
yeah
with two dots at the bottom which is
gives you like an eye sound
but there's also a yah
on my lexi logos keyboard
with no dots underneath it
where's this guy i can't find it on any
list but it shows up on my lexi logos
keyboard and i know it's very useful
because i have to use it from time to
time
there's also aha
with two dots on top it also doesn't
show up on any of these lists that i've
looked at so and again i have it on my
lexi logos keyboard so i find that i
need it
uh i'm doing a lot of typing now using
the dictation function at link so i
study a lesson at link
um
we have you know for example our many
stories we have ten versions of the
minute ten many stories but we're
getting them redone
uh
but uh so i do a lesson and then i go
through for each page that i've done i
don't do the flash cards right now i'm
just doing dictation so i'm forced to
try to type what i hear
the problem is that the text to speech
and even in in human speech it's
difficult to tell what was that was that
a d was it a d was it a the sound was it
a a sound in fact sometimes i think it's
of this sound it's an f sound so
it's difficult so trial and error i try
to
type out that word
it wasn't even close for the longest
while now i'm starting to get the
some of them you know like if you if you
only get one letter wrong they say close
on the system so that's fine but i
actually have hit a few where i thought
what i heard and then i type and of
course the keypad that we use at link it
doesn't give you the letters whereas the
lexi logos it has a b c d so m n i can
go straight to where the most likely
candidate is although in arabic
sometimes you know some sounds have two
symbols that could be this one or could
be that one anyway so that's what i'm
doing i'm struggling i'm working to get
the writing system down so that i can
read because once i can read then there
are some good resources someone
recommended this medina arabic which i
have over here on my computer and it's
really quite good i can i can you know
i'm looking forward to doing it
and you know this
so this is going to give me a little bit
of the sort of structure that i need as
i'm struggling through these lessons but
they introduce they refer to these
arabic words and i want to be able to
read them so my first task if it takes
me a few weeks is to get to where i can
with some confidence get the odd one
wrong even get lots of them wrong but i
can start to feel that i can read the
language so that's where i am right now
working on the arabic letters trying to
get to a level where i can read
and that's all i have to say and and i'm
doing it mostly through a process of
discovery rather than through some
process of explanation like that first
explanation
that i read to you and i look forward to
your comments bye for now
[Music]
you